how is Britain going to build the
workforce it needs to grow it's a
crucial question they're addressing at
this Midlands toolmaker by training
workers in advanced skills a necessity
as the search for staff has got harder
it takes three times as long and costs
you a lot more and you have to work
three times as hard to attract them as
well so
it's not as easy as it was five years
ago to find anybody regardless of the
level in the business that they are
covered in Ukraine have brought huge
challenges but there's another economic
cost business still wants to talk about
110 brexit has made our lives more
difficult in every area of the business
if we can
increase the size of the pool that we're
fishing in by opening out that labor
market uh easing visas or whatever we
have to do it's going to be part of the
solution
the BBI was and remained skeptical about
leaving the EU which is soon act making
his first speech to its annual
conference facing calls to ease
immigration rules a red line he's not
yet ready to cross on trade let me be
unequivocal about this under my
leadership the United Kingdom will not
pursue any relationship with Europe that
relies on alignment with EU laws now I
voted for brexit I believe in brexit and
I know that brexit can deliver and is
already delivering in almost benefits
and opportunities for the country
Britain's relationship with EU is back
on the business agenda because the
economy is desperate for growth and
there is evidence brexit remains a
barrier the office for Budget
responsibility said last week it's
having a significant adverse impact on
trade what this audience wanted to hear
there's some sign the prime minister's
listening to their concerns particularly
around migration but they didn't get it
the cbi's president as the debate is
long overdue we're talking specifically
about economic migration it's not about
the votes in the channel it's about jobs
that can't be filled today there are 1.3
million jobs in Britain that can't be
filled another 52 000 people left the
labor market in the last three months so
we'll get full employment effectively
here those who want a job I've got it
and over here we'll get jobs that we
can't fill
Britain is to make the best of brexit
political and economic reality will have
to get much closer than the last six
years have allowed Paul Kelso Sky News
in Birmingham